on a arrêté de deux hypothèses qui vont
être soumis au
au congrès n'avançant bio bureau
politique puisque ses bureaux politiques
et nos instances de décision là on est
plusieurs d'une formule groupe de
travail dans ce conseiller stratégique
ces deux possibilités pour désigner
notre candidat à la présidentielle soit
on est dans un
système qui est ouvert aux militants
adhérents à jour de cotisation et aux
sympathisants qui se reconnaissent dans
les valeurs de la droite et du centre
est qui acceptent de figurer dans un
fichier qui pourraient être utilisés par
le le vainqueur de l'élection ça c'est
une formule et l'autre formule c'est un
congrès des des militants à jour de
cotisation qui qui voteront qui
désigneront leur le le candidat qui aura
sollicité le parti c'est à dire que
demain soit on a on est dans un système
ouvert aux sympathisants et donc il va
se dérouler
jusque fin novembre ou début décembre on
pourra avoir un congrès un un vote sur
cette procédure début décembre
soit on fait un congrès début décembre
et les candidats qui souhaitent
bénéficier du soutien du parti sollicite
le parti pour avoir ce soutien et les
militants à jour de cotisation votre
voix est donc là on est dans la
rédaction donc c'est un cadre statutaire
donc il faut que tout cela soit rédigée
en termes juridiques et c'est ce que
l'on a préparé ce matin
c'est un système qui est
ouvert effectivement à la fois nos
adhérents mais aussi tous ceux qui se
reconnaissent dans les valeurs de la
droite et du centre alors que le
deuxième système et celui du parti
puisque le parti est celui qui détient
le financement le pouvoir politique et
donc on s'adresse là à ce moment là
uniquement aux adhérents du parti en
leur disant
je sollicite votre soutien pour
l'élection présidentielle est ce que
vous me l'apporté est clairement eu une
idée de faire la primaire la plus
ouverte possible
c'est à dire que là elle est dans le
premier système c'est effectivement
l'ensemble des sympathisants qui se
reconnaissent dans les valeurs de la
droite et du centre clairement ça n'est
pas fait pour les gens qui se
reconnaissent dans les valeurs du front
national ou de l'extrême gauche bien
évidemment comment vous allez définir
d'abord par le fait que
il accepte de figurer sur un fichier que
ce fichier pu être utilisés ensuite
qu'ils soient clairement identifiés
contrairement à la dernière fois c'est à
dire un contrôle de son identité et le
fait qu'il accepte de figurer dans un
fichier en temps
soit
tant que
permettre à des gens qui avaient quand
alors les sur les congrès extraordinaire
on doit être à jour de cotisation 30
jours avant la date du congrès et là on
me proposerait au bureau politique qu'on
fasse une modification jeu soit 15 jours
avant puisqu'on en a maintenant les
moyens de contrôle informatique qui sont
beaucoup plus rapides sur le corps
électoral que ce qu'on avait
précédemment une préférence entre les
deux options moi je dois m'adapter doit
rédiger les deux et quel que soit le
choix des militants ce sera le ce sera
le bon choix les deux ont des avantages
et des inconvénients on l'a déjà évoqué
à plusieurs aplusieurs reprises dans un
cas on est dans un système
beaucoup plus ouvert mais par ailleurs
qui n'a pas la légitimité d'un parti
politique et dans l'autre c'est un parti
politique mais donc par définition ben
il ya moins de personnes qui participent
à ce que ceux qui sont à jour de
cotisation mais je pense qu'on est
arrivé à rédiger de deux formules de
formulation qui sont claires et qui
permettront à nos militants de décider
de toute façon le choix de la méthode ce
sont les militants et l'eire qui en
décideront sur la formulation
on va parler de primaire et ce qu'ils
avaient encore espoir de faire revenir
xavier bertrand dans le giron ce
processus
il ya deux formules moi ce que je
préfère l'idéal pour nous c'est que sur
une formule tout le monde se rassemble
bon xavier bertrand
était
animant relativement clair c'est à dire
qu'il a maintenu sa position sur le
système ouvert en revanche sur le fait
d'aller devant les militants bon il
apparut à s'engager davantage mais après
c'est à lui de le formuler c'est lui qui
est candidat et donc les pour pour nous
l'idéal ce serait effectivement on a
aujourd'hui cinq candidats potentiels
déclaré si les cinq se retrouve sur une
formule c'est parfait
c'est à condition que l'ensemble des
candidats s'ils s'y retrouve donc c'est
pour ça qu'il faut le choisir de manière
dépassionnée c'est le choix d'une
méthode et puis après on rendra campagne
dans dix jours tout cela soit derrière
nous
oui sur les deux formules bon on est sur
l'écriture du texte donc dès qu'on écrit
un texte juridique pas bien évidemment
faut être attentif à tout mais je pense
qu'on va arriver sur un choix qui sera
soumis au bureau politique parce que
c'est le bureau politique formellement
qu'ils arrêtent l'ordre du jour du
congrès
les deux candidats et xavier bertrand
comme valérie pécresse ont quitté notre
partis politiques sont une famille
d'ailleurs les deux ont été élus grâce
au soutien et à l'engagement de du
maître des militants ait l'air et du
parti du parti et l'air il n'aurait pas
été sain sans ça après vous savez
les que ce soit corps électoral plus
large ses idées de notre seul corps
électoral des militants ce qu'ils ont
envie c'est de gagner on l'a vu aux
dernières élections pourquoi on gagne
alors qu'ils aient une abstention très
forte parce que notre notre électorat
était plus mobilisés et un verre envie
de gagner davantage et là on sent que l'
envie de gagner est très forte et on
voit bien que cette présidentielle on
peut tout à fait la gagner si on est
capable d'être assemblés donc moi je
fais confiance au bon sens et à
l'intelligence collective et justement
sur les militants et à son âge qui a été
lancé vous avez déjà eu des premiers
résultats et à quoi ils vont servir
alors cette enquête d'opinion n'est pas
du tout fait sur les militants en effet
sur un corps sur un échantillon qui
était définie de manière scientifique
fois par l'ifop et par pascal perrineau
qui
qui contribuent qui a contribué à la
moye à la fois toute la préparation de
cette enquête d'opinion et puis qu'est
l'autorité politique il travaille dessus
donc cette enquête d'opinion
effet sur un échantillon très large de
15000 personnes
se reconnaissant dans les valeurs de la
droite et du centre et dessus on pose
des questions à la fois sur
les thématiques c'est à dire ce qu
attendent ce qu'attend notre électorat
d'un candidat à la présidence de la
république quels thèmes sont les plus
porteurs ceux sur lesquels on attend les
français attendent une réponse ensuite
sur le mode de départage on les
interroge dessus et puis
sur la personnalité de nos différents
candidats donc ça on aura là le résultat
de cette enquête le 22 septembre
prochain en bureau politique et ce sera
public à ce moment là ce sera présentée
par pascal perrineau et frédéric dabi il
n'y a toujours pas urgence
après sa rentrée regza moore accélère à
droite ça reste inconnu oui mais notre
candidat sera désigné en novembre
ce qu'on a toujours fait et et d'ici là
vous savez vous recevez
la fois sur vos sur vos plateaux et dans
la presse écrite régulièrement nos
différents candidats donc ils font
campagne donc ce n'est pas parce que le
candidat définitif n'ait pas choisi
qu'on ne fait pas campagne la campagne
l'élan s'est déjà depuis au lendemain
des régionales la réalité c'est que la
campagne s'est ouverte là
et on a toujours choisi nos candidats en
fin d'année ce soit jacques chirac
c'était le 4 novembre nicolas sarkozy le
26 novembre françois fillon le 29
novembre vous voyez on est dans cette
période là
où début décembre début des sens c'est
donner une fourchette en gros entre le
25 novembre et le 10 décembre parce
qu'après le 10 décembre on est dans
autre chose